hello everyone welcome back from your
donuts did you
i couldn't finish mine it was like a
weird cheat i don't know anyways it was
very rich
um
yes hello and i just want to say thank
you to all of you and also organizers i
really love this conference it's an
amazing conference i can't believe that
um yeah the first time i came here is
two years ago on a diversity scholarship
so it's been really amazing just coming
back and like all the relationships and
friendships in the community here um
yeah thank you all thank you organizers
you're all amazing
so first hello i'm abby
um in case you don't recognize me
okay
so i work for the mozilla foundation as
lead developer of open source engagement
which means i'm working with open source
community in the different programs part
of mozilla so that includes open science
internet of things women in tech
advocacy learning
also i'm canadian that's very important
yay canada
it's a little bit of history
i came to the tomb the mozilla
foundation through the science lab
before that i was working in research
labs and we're dealing with lots of data
analysis and it was so easy to see how
the web could really make science just
better so that's why i came to mozilla
to help them do that
so mozilla our mission is to ensure the
internet is a global public resource
open and accessible to all
and at the science lab
and most of the work i'm talking about
today will be from when i was at the
science lab specifically
we're applying mozilla's grand mission
to a very interesting community of
practice
so this is my story
a little disclaimer these are not
instructions i know it's titled how to
bring open source to close community
but i hope
the story from the past like seven or
eight years of my life will help you and
you'll learn some lessons to this um
also i'm really i'm willing to hear your
feedback on our plans because we're
starting to bring this to different
communities past just open science uh so
i'd love to hear what you guys think
i mean you all think
okay
so my story starts with open source
um i actually wrote open source code for
years and years before i actually
understood what it was and what it meant
and like what this whole movement was
about
so we're gonna look at the origin of the
term open source um just to help give
some cultural context of the time
because the free software movement
predates this term by quite a few years
like a decade or so
and i know i talk about open source a
lot so i'm gonna do it again for a
little bit because it's very important
so i think it starts with this essay
that eric raymond wrote called um the
cathedral and the bazaar in 1997.
and in this he compared the state of
free software at the time
these two types of free software he saw
and the first was the cathedral
where it's technically public anyone can
come in and take part in a service
but the very few people were in charge
of what was happening there even the way
it's built like an architect and people
were involved with this and you compare
that to a bazaar which is just a public
space and people set up tables and you
can sell whatever you like and you can
barter things and it's really the people
who make this happen
so he saw this happening in linux with
the bazaar
it was like a giant group of people
differing agendas sort of came together
and built something that was better
because of all their diversity
i'm not sure but i think something's on
fire in the bazaar
i'm not really sure but i think that's a
great metaphor for open source maybe
something's on fire who knows
but things get fixed because there's so
many people there
so this essay actually inspired the
netscape corporation to release netscape
browser suite as free software the
following year and that became the basis
of the mozilla project and it inspired
the term open source there's actually a
meeting of like the free software
movement strategy people they were like
oh muslim did something it's we'll call
it open source
so this is really part of like what
mozilla is and what we're trying to do
today in open science and these other
groups
so i know if you remember like the early
2000s but there were no browser wars it
was just internet explorer and the fact
that this community could come together
and build something that toppled a giant
was really amazing
and it really pointed to this idea that
we're all better together
yeah diverse group people to get working
on a problem
but like how do we get this diverse
group together
and the way mosul approaches that is
through this idea of working open
that things are both public and
participatory
so we need to restructure efforts that
outsiders can meaningfully participate
and become insiders as appropriate i
think that's a little key that made me
understand how like what open source is
and how this movement sort of works and
engages people
so shortly after they made up the term
open source
the open source initiative
started and i think this really
is why open source is still here today
they outlined like 10 steps in how you
are a real open source project so thanks
to all the people there
so back to my story
i learned about open source but then
also science i was working in
bioinformatics and like a cancer
research institute
and
i won't go too deep into this but
sometimes
trying to participate in science can
feel like this
this is
a few great illustrations from john
mckiernan on wyoming research
but especially after i left academia
there was i couldn't get to research
anymore but even when i was within
academia it was only the specialist that
could really participate in something
and help make discoveries
and when you are in this community
you're always scared of getting scooped
um you're worried that someone else will
publish before you and you won't get the
credit for it and i think it's just a
lack of education on
yeah how open licenses can protect you
and help you
so one of the first things we tried to
do to help bring open source into
science
when i joined the science lab was this
collaborate which is a collection of
open source projects for science and
it's still there it looks different now
and it's still great you have a bunch of
open source projects but something i
realized was that um
in general we weren't that great at open
source
researchers people would come to the
projects but they wouldn't know how to
get involved or things weren't laid out
well people weren't responsive
so i realized there was a culture change
that needed to happen so that research
could be more open and could participate
more open source
so it brings us to the third point in my
story fueling the movement
and this is actually the last point in
my story and most of my talk will be
this one
if you're taking notes i don't know i
like
like making lists of three you're gonna
see lists of three many more times
so
i actually couldn't find a good
definition of a movement that i liked so
i'm defining it here
as mobilizing a community around a
shared purpose
um i don't know if that's there's
probably a better definition but i like
this one because you need a community
for culture change you need to mobilize
people so they're actually doing
something
so i like this diagram or yeah so this
is a dancing guy
this is from a ted talk by derek sivers
i don't know if i'm saying that right
but he was talking about movements and
how one guy dancing can inspire someone
else to come and join you and it starts
mobilizing people and eventually you see
some cool stuff happening over there
maybe someone else is going to join
maybe someone else is going to join
this is really funny to watch
you can see the whole thing online but
slowly like more people get involved and
it's not just one guy dancing anymore
it's a group of them
and
that mobilizes other people oh yay
someone came
and
this is just really funny i like the
shaky cam too
and then more and more people
oh man okay
i'm falling down we'll just watch this
for a second it's a lot of fun yay
there's a group so now it's a group
dancing it's no longer just one person
doing his own thing but now this is
something people are taking notice of
and then even bystanders if you're
bystanders yeah if you're on the edge
and you don't know what to do suddenly
it makes more sense for you to join than
to just
sit around so i really like this
yeah i like this as like a description
of a movement visually
okay moving on
so this is a figure from marshall
gantz's essay public narrative
collective action and power um which i
would recommend if you're interested in
cultural change
but he talks about how to get people to
take action so now if we're actually
trying to mobilize these people he talks
about how you need two things both
strategy and narrative so you need to
have like the head knowledge of what you
need to do but also the narrative of why
this is important
so talking to researchers i think they
all understood why it was important they
know that sharing data
is better but they didn't have a good
strategy on how to do that without like
killing their career or
not knowing what to do
so
i made a plan to fuel the movement
another list of three things
first was resources to help with that
strategy to give people that
then talking to leaders and mobilizing
them so that they can mobilize other
people through mentorship and keep the
movement going
like the dancing guy okay
oh so first on resources
um we're actually doing a little
exercise that i did with the science
team
on trying to brainstorm like what kind
of steps people need to do this so
how do outsiders become insiders today
this is what working open is
so everyone think of a place you felt
welcomed the first time you visited
so give you free few seconds
think
okay what place are you thinking of
you can yell it out
oh strange loop yeah that's i heard
brain flu at first which made no sense
strange loop yeah i definitely felt
welcome that strangely
canada yes
um i don't remember when i first came to
canada but i'm sure i felt welcome
any other places
college
that's that can be
true for some people and not true for
others that's great yeah
any others
where was that
niagara falls oh it's beautiful
the canada side
just checking
cool so now for all those places
uh what made it welcoming it's a strange
loop back there
yo what made strange loop welcoming for
you
the people
were they like the people were welcoming
they just said hi to you in the hallways
and stuff
yeah that's great in case you didn't
hear that yeah everyone wants to find
out who you are and what you're doing
and it's they encourage you to keep
doing that um for me actually um
since i was on that diversity
scholarship they had a special dinner
for
i think it was actually for like lambda
ladies but they invited all the
scholarship people there and that was
great it was like a smaller place for me
to get welcome and it was people who
were similar to me which was nice
what else made strangely welcoming for
the rest of you anything else
the people donuts yeah they keep us well
fed
they they tend to our other needs like
when we're hungry um we have places to
sit
talk to each other yes
yeah the slacks so that's another way
for you to communicate and get involved
and to know what's going on yeah those
are all great ways uh what about what
were the other ones canada what made
canada welcoming
politeness
they keep you
yes all the maple syrup you want
it's not true it's quite pricey no
poutine
poutine is pretty great too you should
all have poutine i didn't mean for this
talk to be so canadian
i'm really sorry
i'm also saying sorry okay
um what was some of the other ones i
can't remember them anymore
oh college what made college welcoming
for you
the the people and the
the organization the like
um onboarding
yeah orientation they usually have like
a whole week for that and it's all about
meeting people and you have fun things
going on yeah college is really great at
that
so some things that were welcoming was
like being welcomed by people um having
good onboarding so you know what to do
how you're supposed to act
um being polite
tending to your needs so feeding you
that
yeah
i'm trying to apply that if it doesn't
make sense anyways
what does this look like in software
so how can we be welcoming and polite
and tend to their needs in software
yes not being a jerk is the key point
there but yeah answering people's
questions about being a jerk it's very
canadian of you
anything else
showing people where this gets started
yeah showing people where to get started
along with that not assuming that
everybody's been doing this for 10 years
yes but like making your documentation
and computing guidelines
yeah so making everything beginner
friendly not assuming people have been
doing this all for 10 years
having contributor guidelines i think
that's also great
yeah spending time with newcomers i
think that's really great um where would
you do that
yeah
um
oh yeah
that's really nice yeah yeah so chatting
them with them on gitter slack even
skype
i think even before people reach out
having
something like in your readme so people
can passively see where to go
it's good so
at the science lab we thought about this
we did the same exercise maybe a little
bit longer but we came up with this
checklist of things
for open source and we wrote um little
exercises for each one so those are all
links so we have public repository we
didn't really talk about that but like
being somewhere where people can find
you
if this is all on your computer no one
can come and contribute
we were covering all our bases
having an open license so you actually
meet the open source definition would be
good um having a readme where you're
welcoming people
a roadmap something we didn't really
talk about but having your issues broken
down um or just have so that people can
know where they can come into your
project and what they can work on
having code of conduct we didn't mention
actually but um especially here at
strange loop like we have a code of
conduct which i think is great and
there's ways to level up your concerns
so i think having them on an open source
project i know it's not super common yet
but i think it should be
contributing guidelines we talked about
so people know how they can contribute
and then this last one is kind of vague
i just say mentorship but this is more
about the attitude that you need to be
welcoming people into your project and
then helping them learn as they go
through bugs and helping them learn to
yeah even be a better coder
so fueling the movement those were the
resources we put together
so now part two is finding leaders
so we ran this workshop the working open
workshop
um in berlin back in february where we
picked a bunch of people from our
community who were running really cool
open source projects some of them were
on that
collaborate list i showed you earlier
they they're already running open source
projects they know that this is what
they want to do
and maybe just a little bit of strategy
would help activate them so we brought
them all to berlin
and part of helping activate them was
working with them after the workshop
um
yeah so
here's the
okay we're going to start at this giant
diagram
up at the top it's abby and irelia i'm
abby
irelia is the community lead with the
mozilla science lab she's also um yeah a
great open source developer and like a
map geek she's a lot of fun
so those are the two of us and then we
had
uh all these people at the working open
workshop that showed up
there's 22 of them
and all but two of them wanted to be
part of our open leadership cohort we
named a bunch of things i'm sorry if it
gets confusing
but these are people who agree to meet
with us
for the next three months for one-on-one
mentorship to apply the lessons they had
learned at the working open workshop to
their projects
and at the end of that we were going to
have the global sprint which is like a
two-day hackathon so they're just
getting their projects ready for a giant
hackathon basically
so we met with them for 30 minutes every
two weeks and mostly we just work with
them to set goals it's like oh what do
you want your project to look like in
three months for the hackathon and
they'll say things like oh like be ready
for contributors so that we can actually
get good contributions happening at the
hackathon and we'd hold them accountable
by checking in with them every couple
weeks
so soon after that we actually added
quite a few people to our open
leadership cohort
because they had co-leads on their
projects
so they we also met with them
and then at the global sprint these are
the people
that made significant contributions to
their projects so they wanted to shout
them out and give them a little thanks
so this is a little screenshot of what
happened at the global sprint so it's 40
sites around the world a two-day
hackathon and basically it starts in new
zealand and then it like goes around the
world to australia asia europe and then
just sort of goes around the world twice
everyone's working nine to five in their
time zone it's really fun and it's just
two days of working on science things so
it was a good goal to work towards as
people have these projects that they're
trying to make open source
yeah
i explained that
so the global sprint we had all these
new people yay
so
now for that third part of fueling the
movement mentorship
so
we had them
sort of mentoring those people that came
and got involved at the global sprint
but we wanted them to start practicing
to mentor new people
and we wanted to sort of branch out of
just open science to other parts of
mozilla
so we selected mentors for round two
these are people that we thought would
be good mentors
and then
we gave them mentees
as part of our mentorship program and
they started mentoring these people so
these
bottom dots
um
sorry this isn't the best diagram i made
it pretty quickly
but they're all nominated from different
parts of mozilla so some of these are
internet of things hackers some of them
are part of the women in web literacy
group some of them are from our open
advocacy stuff for the well open web
advocates yeah that's what they're
called
so now i'm going to tell you some
stories and lessons from going through
this whole program
and what happened
oh and also i forgot to mention at the
global sprint this year because we had
done this mentorship the amount of
contributorship just like skyrocketed
because we had measured the github
activity the previous two years at our
global sprint and then this year i
probably should have made a graph maybe
you can imagine it with my arms it goes
like this
very scientific i know
but there was so much more interaction i
think especially because we focused on
using github for collaboration so
there's a lot of like issues and
discussions which scientists were much
more likely to get involved when because
they like mailing lists
so
open source checklist so we're going to
go through this whole checklist
and i'll tell you a little story about
one of the people in our program and
also
tell you a bit about what we taught them
in each of our pieces
so first person is a chintya
so this is acentia
this is this github profile picture
oh for all of these people i didn't tell
them i was talking about them so i hope
they don't mind
hello recording okay
achindia is a science communicator at
cern
um and he's a phd student and science
community phd student in science
communication at uwe bristol
so
his project was open cosmics yeah it
does fulfill cosmic ray physics for
everyone so for a little physics primer
cosmic rays are high-energy particles
that bombard the earth's atmosphere and
then they produce these shower particles
that we can measure here on earth so
there's actually um crayfish you can
install it on your phone it's an app
that will like measure cosmic ray
particles
which is kind of cool and you can also
build your own cosmic ray like measuring
things
out of like plastic bottles i'm not sure
how it works but it's also cool
but the problem was there's all these
different ways to measure cosmic rays
from like the real detectors to your own
homemade bottle
but the data was very varied and there
was no standards so achintia was like
hey i'm going to bring all these people
together and we're going to make a
standard that way people can share this
data across each other with each other
yeah
so
he's a little special because if you see
those three green dots that he brought
on those are all these people that were
running these projects from like the the
one on your phone to the other homemade
one and there's also cosmic pie which
from what i understand is raspberry pi
for cosmic ray physics it's kind of cool
and he needed to get people to
collaborate around something and discuss
with each other so by giving him a
github repository it gave him a place to
collaborate and just sort of coordinate
with these people and afterwards he said
the biggest thing he learned
from going through this whole system was
how to project manage on github which
isn't really what we were trying to
teach him but it's cool that by putting
something online it's you're more
organized so
make sure your code is available
all those are acceptable and then we
have um
this curriculum called github for
collaboration which really walks you
through how you like make a pull request
and how you collaborate with each other
and discuss things in issues which a lot
of scientists are very new to so that
helped attention quite a lot
the next thing was having an open
license and we're going to talk about
rob
this is rob
oh i have another picture of rob
he's the fuzzy one over there
yeah so this is at our working open
workshop we're doing the open web
stretch we're leaning left to avoid the
nsa
but he's working on a project um i think
it might be cut off no it's okay it's
called pmc ref so pubmed central
is um this repository for life science
and biomedical
research articles
so what he wanted to do was you give it
an article and then he will give back
all the articles that you can read for
free on pubmed central so it's a little
simple thing but very useful for someone
in the biological sciences
i'm highlighting him under license
because i noticed he made a license like
four days after our workshop
so i think everyone else like ignored me
for a while or already had licenses so
that's why rob gets a shout out here
thanks rob
mit license very permissive way to go
so if we remember rob's that one there
little red dot
and
he was that this is his first open
source project that he was running and
he was actually able to get someone to
contribute quite a lot
the yellow dot attached to his red dot
at the sprint and that was actually her
first open source contribution so yeah
it was made possible and it was legal
because he had an open license
and now he's mentoring someone
in our next round this guy named min
he's going to be at the mozilla festival
which is what this round ends at
where
it's this art display with facial
recognition so when you walk by it will
recognize your face if you walked by
before and tell things about you so it's
supposed to like highlight security and
privacy on the web anyways it should be
cool also a little creepy but um those
are the cool projects that are in this
network
so yes open license
the science lab recommends mit or bsd
also we just point people to
chooselicense.com which is an excellent
resource if you're looking for an open
license
next on the checklist is kirsty
on readme
so here's kirsty
um she's actually one of our 2016
mozilla fellows for science so we also
have a fellowship program where early
career researchers
will basically do open science for a
year while we pay them to stay in their
universities and just bring open science
there so kirsty is one of them she did a
great job and she was part of
yeah our community all last year so she
is a postdoc researcher at the brain
mapping unit and at the university of
cambridge
but the project she worked on when she
was part of this mentorship
was stem role models
where she wanted um to inspire future
generations by providing the most
exciting and very diverse speakers for
your conference
so she actually really took to heart
this you need to be welcoming in your
project and she made her all her
documentation was super welcoming he's
like welcome first and foremost welcome
emoji welcome in another emoji
emoji emoji it was very exciting
so
here she is and yeah she was able to get
a couple people to help her because her
tech skills aren't as strong so she got
some people to help build this database
of role models
which is really cool and now she's
mentoring a few other people including
um
two people from the detroit community
tech project and they're
making this cool music box thing which
is addressing gentrification in detroit
and like enable using open source
technology to help storytelling in that
area which is really cool so
another project yeah they're the red
ones
but for project communication so we have
a handout called open project
communication
here
and one of my favorite things in this is
actually the open canvas that we made um
have any of you heard of lean canvas
yeah someone so it's really popular in
like the business startup world um
an entrepreneur will like fill out the
lean canvas that's
like a one-page business plan so it goes
through like problem solution like what
you're trying to do so we remixed it and
we took out the parts that were very
like business specific and added things
for open source like contributors and
user profiles
and i think this is really important
because it makes you think about what
you're building the product then also
the community you're trying to build
with it
um yep so you have users and
contributors and i like this green
square for project execution because i
find a lot of people don't think about
the kind of contributors they need in
relation to what they're trying to build
so if you have if you know what your mvp
is your minimum viable product
and what you need for that if you need
designers and a developer you make sure
you put that in your contributors that
you need designers and developers and
then think about how you will onboard
designers if you don't know any
so that's really useful i found and it
helps you write a better readme
if you actually know like your problem
and solution
so that was
i can go back i'm sorry
cool so next one's a road map with
bastion
there's bastion
he's off on the side so
i was really excited um when i paired
bastian with his mentee for this round
because his mentee emailed me back and
was like i can't believe my mentor is
the mark zuckerberg of open source
genetics and he linked me to this
article
and i was like i had no idea
but bastian's pretty cool
he runs opensnip.org
snip is for a single nucleotide
polymorphism which is kind of mutation
you get in
your genome but basically it's um if
you've ever done 23andme or any of those
things that genotypes you you can upload
the results to openstip.org and it's
public and people can use it for
research and you can also match it to
phenotypes so you can see
um yeah what the phenotypes would look
like in use like
it will predict oh you're eastern
european or something like that so oh
fun story um
when bastian uploaded his genotype
before opens he made opensnip um he put
it on github and some random researcher
came along and like analyzed his genome
and then emailed him
and was like hey you have like a higher
likelihood for prostate cancer and
bastian was like oh dear um
but he he was pretty young but he told
his dad and his dad went and got checked
and they caught the cancer early enough
that he was um
yeah he's alive and well now so it's
cool uh you should share your genome
okay
but we helped them through road mapping
oh that's what it was road mapping
even just helping them sort through what
features they wanted over the next few
months and break that down helps them
actually get things done over the next
few months yeah
otherwise
they hadn't been doing a lot for the
year before that so road mapping can
help sort of get your community a
kickstart and help new people come in so
they know what you're working on next
and where they can help
so we have a little like introduction to
road mapping so it helps you break down
milestones and break things down into
issues
yeah
and next on the open source checklist is
a code of conduct where we have richard
this is richard he has a moss beard
um here's another picture of him with no
beard
so richard yeah he's on the left there
this is at mozfest you should all come
to mozfest but
basically oh i didn't make another slide
for him yeah he worked on a lot of
projects this year because he was
actually fellow this past year so one of
the projects he worked on was
slidewinder where he wanted to make
presentations better
so that you can like
remix your html presentations easier
like you can with keynote and stuff
anyways it's cool it's called
slidewinder he wrote a cool code of
conduct for that he was also working on
science fair
which was for like sharing papers and
reading papers
which is more useful for scientists but
he always has a code of conduct and he's
always very aware that it is difficult
for people to come into these projects
so
um i like to point out his code of
conduct oh yeah slidewinder code of
conduct and here are a couple of
resources on how to write a code of
conduct
and links to some good stuff oh and the
mozilla science lab has a code of
connect which is cc0 so you can just
take it for yourself if you like you
don't even have to credit us
next is contributing.md contributor
guidelines and tim
so there's tim
so he worked on everywhere i don't know
why they're slogans sharing is caring i
guess yeah sharing your research is good
but he cares a lot about reproducible
research and this basically um
yeah it lets you run other people's
github code in a
wait yeah on ipython notebook in github
it'll launch it in a docker instance so
you can see it and then you can edit it
anyways it's cool
i first met tim at a hackathon at cern
and he got into an argument with one of
the judges
about whether or not science was
reproducible at cern he was saying we
can be more reproducible which is why we
need this and she was like we're already
reproducible anyways
reproducible science is very important
but he wrote a great contributing
guidelines and was able to
bring in quite a few people onto this
project um i think i yeah so all the
yellow parts that came on before the
global sprint and now he's mentoring um
oh yeah some other people doing
reproducible science work
cool so
for those of you
yeah a little intro and contributing
guidelines um they're in your root
directory we use adam here as an example
they did a pretty good job
and it's good to um
have some cheer welcome people
have a nice introduction
um give instructions on like how to
contribute or how to run your things and
then yeah style guidelines it's down
there
but what's cool about contributing
guidelines is that github has made them
pretty popular because it's pretty
integrated with github now so if you
open a new issue like here it actually
has this little message at the top
saying like please review our
contributing guidelines so
it helps if you have them so people can
read them before they make issues on
your projects
okay so the last one here is mentorship
our big broad one and i put madeline
there she's pretty cool
this is madeline
she's a phd student at the university of
toronto
here's another picture of her she's here
on the left
she actually spoke at our working open
workshop because she actually runs a
weekly meeting
at u of t
on like open science and doing open
science so she helped talk about that
but she has a pretty cool project called
phage parser
which is around the crispr system so if
you crispr is like really cool nowadays
and quite a buzzword because of all the
genome editing stuff it can do so it
stands for clustered regularly
interspaced short palindromic repeats
that's a lot but it's basically um all
of the
the black squares oh yeah i can walk
i forgot my mic's like not okay so all
these are repeats
these are all the same part of the gene
and then these extra parts over here
they're from viruses that have attacked
the crispr system so crisp it can
actually remember what the virus is like
it keeps the hold of this and then what
it does is it can identify the virus
later and then like cut it which is why
it's so great at genome editing because
it helps us
like cut genomes exactly where we want
them to be
um
but what madeline noticed and her phd
advisor noticed is that a lot of people
were
they were publishing
bacterial and rkl genomes that have
crispr systems
and we could analyze all that and find
out about um
all this virus dna in between like what
can we learn about crisprs because it's
a little there's a little bit of
unknowns in there
so that's a cool project and she was
able to engage like a lot of people on
there so like all those four
this long stage
yeah like all those four people were
like new contributors at the global
sprint
also i think it helps that she runs the
open science meetup so she can just like
get people from both
and she's mentoring people now including
faye who runs
the mozilla community in the philippines
and she's like making curriculum and how
to um
yeah i think it's like how to run campus
campaigns in the philippines i don't
i don't remember exactly i should have
written notes anyways
so curriculum stuff that we have under
mentorship
um
the idea is good first bugs is labeling
some of your issues as good first bugs
is a good entry point for people who
come into your project
and then we also have a personas and
pathways exercise which is used a lot in
the design world but i think we can use
it for open source too since we're
trying to figure out pathways for our
open source contributors it's good if
you
think of a persona like have a made-up
contributor
and make a pathway for them to walk
through
so
that's a resource you can use to make up
some personas
so to summarize this is our open source
checklist
many things
and
oh yes and we feel the movement by
making these resources
mobilizing leaders and then having them
mentor others so we'll see how well that
works
having scientists mentor people from all
other places but i think it'll be great
so you can come to mozfest which is
october 28th to 30th ravensbourne london
and
oh yeah the tagline is the world's
leading event for and by the open
internet movement join us to build
debate and explore the future
of our lives online let's cut off a bit
but i really like moss best because like
we have an open science space every year
but there's also a whole floor for open
news and a whole floor for like advocacy
and
it's really cool just to see all these
places interact so moz is designed to be
like the web a place where you can make
things that matter
so these are all the people that helped
or they're in the mentorship program or
their mentors you guys have been
awesome any questions
it seems to me yep talked a lot about
issues related to the friction of people
becoming involved but my experience in
science engineering is a motivational
component of this as well it's not clear
i mean a lot of the issues that i see
deal with people's fear or paranoia
about being more open
so it's not it's not really
to me it's not the intimidation of
getting involved and finding out that
it's an uphill thing there's a learning
room it's more that they're just not
motivated to do it
yeah and i think um there's a lot of
good resources like wyomingresearch.com
that addresses a lot of those fears um
yeah i don't i don't have too much in
this presentation about that i think
that's a really good point
i would yeah i would take them to
wyomingresearch.com
um
there's probably other places
but yeah happy to chat more
anything else
cool well enjoy your last keynote thanks
all
oh
and the slides are there if you want to
click on all my links
thanks
you